but I think the debate here that's what
a great job nationalist politicians have
done in the last hundred to two hundred
years in bringing about imagined
communities and imagine boundaries
because ultimately it's funny that it
takes a Terp to say this it takes a
Muslim to say this but I think we're all
Romans and it's about probability it's
highly probable that we Romans as
subjects of the Roman Empire we have a
high probability of interacting with
each other and traveling in the Roman
domains for example apostolos if he were
still living in let's say Istanbul I
would be calling him room Roman when
Mehmed the second the Ottoman Sultan
conquered Constantinople he didn't call
himself the Sultan of the Ottomans he
called himself the Caesar of the Romans
johnny is never a part of the Roman
Empire what it is let us special the
argument is hey Germany now there was no
the birth Britain was always a
troublemaker of order for the Romans but
if it'll take some time it'll take take
some time but I think ultimately for the
last 2,000 years from Lebanon to
Anatolia to the British frontier we have
been part and parcel of a common area we
have been traveling intermarrying
killing each other in my hometown bush
normal family we are we are at European
family er a European family for example
in my hometown versa the first capital
of the Ottoman Empire I was just
visiting the local synagogue which was
caught which is called my or synagogue
there's 60 Jews living in Bursa and
there is a synagogue called my or
synagogue why because this is the
Sephardic Jews from the island of
Majorca now nationalist politicians have
made us forget about those
inter-linkages why because it's
challenging it challenges our nation
state model I'm sorry to say the
boundaries are imagined the communities
are imagined the connections are real we
have been traveling trading
marrying each other killing each other
for over 2,000 years we're not doing it
to the same extent with the Chinese
we're not doing it to the same extent
with South Africa or South America we
love and hate each other in this part of
the region in an intense way and this is
actually what precedes the 200 years of
nation states and I think now the task
is not to invent the European identity
the task is to forget the nationalist
rhetoric of the last 200 years so that
we can once again begin to realize why
do we call the poet Rumi you know that
the patron saint of the whirling
dervishes why is he called the Roman
he's not called the Muslim he's not
called the Eastern he is known around
the world as Rumi the Roman because he
although he was composing poetry in
Persian and farsi he was a man of the
Roman domains and he belongs more to
Europe than to the Islamic Republic of
Iran and that's why we are Europeans
ladies and gentlemen
at this point you should tell the story
about German students though you asked
whether it was killed them I think it's
yeah very apt well first of all it
obviously takes a Turk to tell us why
Europe is worth living and that says an
awful lot about Europe secondly this
story I'll apostolis mentioned I wrote a
book about the years before the first
world war and that entailed quite a lot
of lecturing last year and I wasn't a
little German town and I spoke on the
same day to two schools one was a
gymnasium sore senior so high school for
high academic achievers and one was a
real tool which is sort of vocational
school and I went to the gymnasium and
there were 16 year old kids and it was
close to the anniversary of the
beginning of the First World War and you
know the hundreds of thousands of young
people rushing to the flag and i asked
the 16 year old kids any of you boys
here if Angela Merkel now said the
eastern Ukraine is a terrible mess we're
going to war who if you would volunteer
and they looked at me at me as if I were
fridge they looked at me as a vol crazy
the idea and then I went to the
vocational school and asked the same
question and out of 50 boys or so for
raised their hands three wolf Turkish
descent and I think that says a lot
about first of all the felt pressure to
assimilate to show that you're a good
German that you're willing to do
something for your adopted country but
perhaps also about different concepts of
masculinity of honor and but it was it
was a very striking fact and there was
in to school classes effectively one as
I heard a bio German who would have said
yes I think that's a good idea it also
teaches you essentially sorry a
different concept of self yes a
different concept of self sacrifice and
of course a fantastically gigantic
cultural change
can you imagine if I'd asked that in
1914 what would have happened to the boy
who hadn't stuck up his hand so yes I
think I think it is a good sign
you